okay so
this month we're going to talk about
winrt
uh programming to win rt with standard c
plus plus using c plus slash winrt
and i'm not going to go into
super low level detail
on
this stuff because there are already
great cppcon videos that cover it
by the implementers kenny kerr
and uh
james mcnellis
although i think the implementation is
by kenny kerr and james mcnellis was
just one of the presenters on one of the
talks but
um
so let's just start out with a brief
history of programming
to windows
we started with
win16 on dos
which is a 16-bit
it's you know it's object-oriented in
quotes it's a c api and objects are
represented by handles
and when you want to make a method call
it's basically a c function call with
the handle as the first argument to the
function
and then
with win 9x and windows nt
we got
win32
which is 32-bit api but it still handles
but
in win32 they started introducing
services through interfaces exposed via
com and we'll talk about com in a second
win64 is really just 64-bit variant of
win32 so
win64 it's kind of more like uh an
implementation detail in in the sense
that
people just generically talk about win32
as the api for windows
and
you know whether it is 64-bit pointers
the 32-bit pointers the api doesn't
really matter it's just a matter of how
you build the code as not so much as
that there's different apis for the
different
platforms 64-bit platform versus a
32-bit platform
and now they have win-rt which is the
windows runtime
and
i think officially they spell runtime as
one word not two as i've got it there
but
this is a pure object oriented api and
everything is exposed as objects via com
so in win32
because
it originates as a c api with its win16
heritage
the newer features of the operating
system show up as com interfaces and you
have to deal with that
and they actually have a method for
mechanically generating a c api for all
of the com
interfaces and their methods
although i i literally know
zero people who have ever programmed to
that but it's possible
everybody by the time com comes along
they're using c plus and interacting
with interfaces
so what is this com thing well it's the
component object model and this is a
binary interface standard for software
components first introduced in 1993
that's almost 30 years ago so this
thing's been around for a while it's
tried true and tested
and
what's also interesting about it is that
it's language neutral so the software
landscape in 1993 looked a little bit
different
object oriented pascal
was popular from a a product that
borland made called delphi
and visual basic was popular
uh
before eve even before the popularity of
visual basic six which is where com
really took off but
uh and c was popular and c plus plus was
becoming more popular
so being language neutral was important
it is com is object oriented so
everything is through objects there's
a few
global functions
that are what you use to get bootstrap
your way to your first object interface
but otherwise everything is built around
interfaces
and
com just specifies a base level
infrastructure for
getting objects creating an instance of
an object obtaining interfaces from an
object an object may implement one or
more it has to implement at least one
interface
and from that one interface every object
is required to implement which is called
i unknown
you can query for other interfaces that
the object may implement
and
com also specifies
the infrastructure for managing the
object lifetimes it's basically
reference counting
and in com
you're both a consumer of interfaces and
a producer of interfaces
and in the more complex standards that
are built on top of the com mechanisms
sometimes the application implements an
interface and acts as a sink to the
system
and other times the application consumes
an interface and acts as a
a source the the interface is the system
is the source and the application is
pulling from the system by making method
calls on the interface
when the application acts as a sync it
gives its interface implementation
pointer to the system and then the
system calls back into the application
by making method calls on the interface
and that's syncing data into the
application
so
you can also use this infrastructure for
creating your own components and
creating your own
object-oriented binary
component mechanism within your
application within a suite of
applications
uh whether you choose to register them
with the system or not is up to you
you know
you can use all these mechanisms for
your own internal objects without
registering these objects on the system
and
therefore other applications can't
invoke pieces of your insides you know
so you can keep your proprietary
stuff proprietary but you can still take
advantage of the mechanisms
so stuff you might have heard of that's
built on com ole object linking and
embedding this is when you have a live
excel spreadsheet inside a word document
the way that works is there's an
instance of excel that's running
and it exposes the functionality through
a set of interfaces that it implements
and then the word document is hosting
the instance of excel inside it and
negotiating the user interface all the
key all the mouse clicks and all the
keystrokes and all of that it's
a cooperative arrangement
that is spelled out in a big pile of
interfaces that are implemented by
objects and that's what allows a word to
be a host
for the embedded object and it's what
allows excel to be an embedded object
hosted by
another application
ole automation
is on top of all that and that provides
a mechanism to expose com objects and
their interfaces to scripting languages
scripting languages being more dynamic
so they
they can't statically bind themselves to
the interfaces the interfaces have to
have some way of describing themselves
so that
the scripting language can query what
the method strings are for instance and
how to pass arguments back and forth all
of that stuff is specified through
ole automation
if you've done any game or graphics pro
3d graphics programming on windows
not using opengl then you were probably
using direct3d which is part of directx
and that's all com based so it's all
methods on objects
if you wanted to extend
the windows gui
that is done through the windows shell
and it's it's again you implement
interfaces that
the shell specifies
for your
extension
and you register those extensions with
the shell and now
your dll is getting invoked by the
windows shell
and while that's a really cool concept
it's also the reason why sometimes you
context menu on an item in the file
system and it takes a really long time
for the context menu to get populated
and that's because it's going and
scraping everything up out of the
registry to find out who's registered
for this kind of object type in the file
system and who's providing possible
extensions to the context menu because
it can't
dynamically add those extensions in as
it discovers them it goes and discovers
everything first and then builds the
menu
the popularity of vb6 visual basic six
where you could drag and drop components
to build a gui
um
it's kind of the predecessor of windows
forms in c sharp
in terms of that drag and drop
construction methodology for building up
a gui
um really vb6 is the thing that made com
objects become a huge market success
um because
it meant i could write
a
an efficient object that does some task
in c plus
and because my object is written to
support interface via com
which is language neutral it could be
consumed from bv6
and
everything just worked
so vb6
drop all these objects together to build
up your form write some events to glue
everything together some event handlers
poof you know now i've got an
application
and he could do um
a lot of interesting things that way
um
and then there's this thing called the
dot-net platform
is net implemented on com
no
it's influenced by the experience of
using com for the 10 years prior to net
being introduced and it has a lot of
similarities
it's easy to consume com objects
from.net and it's easy to implement com
objects from.net
and net interoperates with com really
well
but it isn't implemented via com
in other words com is not the enabling
technology that creates.net
although it they play really well
together but it's a completely separate
thing it has a virtual machine which is
not part of com
it has
the
um intermediate language which is the
you know the virtual machine
assembly language for
that net and all of it has all those
other things
so there's similarities but it it is not
um
implemented using com
so what is winrt um
windows runtime
is a platform agnostic component and
application architecture implemented in
c plus plus that's how wikipedia
describes it
and
you know for a while microsoft
their you know their marketing
department always seems to
muddy the waters shall we say
there was a while where winrt which is
what i think of as this api
they were kind of labeling it as
you know the next version of windows or
the
um
the name for the gui or whatever just
the
i i can't tell you the number of people
i've talked to and i said oh you know
it's done using winrt and they're like
oh winrt is dead it's not a thing and
i'm like yes it is we're talking about
two different things
and the one you are talking about that
is dead that isn't a thing is a fault of
the marketing department has nothing to
do with the technology
but really windows
runtime is a new version of the windows
api where the entire api is accessed via
com
interfaces
and
there's um
because there's this
kind of uh layer of indirection through
interfaces
when rt applications can be run in a
sandboxed environment kind of you know
they can have this spun up little mini
virtual machine for it
um
it
allows winrt applications to be sold
through the windows store and be
certified
um it can the sandboxing
makes it less likely that one of these
applications
could make a permanent change to your
system
settings or anything like that
it's the whole point of running things
into sandbox
but more importantly all the services
are provided through com via interfaces
unlike the win32 api where some things
are provided through c api style
functions and other things are provided
through com generally the more recent
things are provided through com and the
older things are through functions
and
the interfaces here are described by
language agnostic metadata
and there's a
ecma standard that they created for
net
that describes
the format of the metadata files so
anybody could parse them if they wanted
to anybody could write tools that parse
the files
that hold the metadata the metadata is
the one true source of information about
the api
so each language that wants to target
winrt
uses a language projection that exposes
the interface as described in the
metadata to that programming language in
as natural way as possible
and winrt includes many of the same
components that are familiar to csharp
and net developers
i don't know what the crossover there is
or crossover is there but i i believe
it's
um
at least as far as the winrt surface
everything you could see from dot net
you can see from c plus
does that mean that there are things
accessible in dot net that aren't
accessible from c plus sure because as i
said
net is a completely separate platform
and although it interoperates with com
just because something is available in
dot net doesn't mean it's available as a
com object
and at a bare minimum something has to
be available as a com object to be in
winrt
now i believe it's microsoft's intention
to provide
parity between
winrt and the.net
platform
but i don't know
off the top of my head you know to what
extent they've been able to accomplish
that but as we'll we'll look at a more
example of advanced example later
and we'll see that it it
it looks pretty darn close
so what is c plus slash win rt so it's
the c plus plus language projection for
the winrt api
um it uses only
iso c plus plus 17
so no language extensions no msvc
specific code
you can even compile it with clang
if you want to compile your code with
clang for instance as we discussed last
month you might want to be using clang
to get better error diagnostics so not
going to be a problem
they ship a tool called cppwinrt
and this is the tool that reads the the
winrt metadata
and generates a header only library
that allows you to call
the functions
or the methods and interfaces described
by the metadata
so this is handy because if you get a
third-party winrt component
and say that component doesn't ship with
a c plus language projection but it does
ship with component metadata so you can
generate the c plus plus language
projection yourself for that third-party
component
um you can also use it to
you know for whatever reason if you want
to
you can regenerate
the language projection for the entire
winrt system
so the system api
why would you want to do that well
it the projections ship with the windows
sdk
but you might want to
generate
a subset of
the metadata into the header only
library
put that into your source tree so that
when you build your application you're
building for a specific version of the
winrt runtime
uh rather than requiring people that
want to build your code say it's an open
source application
to have the particular version of the
windows sdk that has that particular
uh metadata version on it
so how does this stuff work well it's a
header only library so you
would guess correctly that templates are
involved
template classes are used to provide
marshalling shims to cross the comm
barrier
and what that means is
as a consumer of these interfaces you
get something that is clean and you
don't have to worry about low level
details
and
the as i said the com objects are
lifetime managed by reference count so
constructors add the reference and
destructors remove the reference and
everything just works as as when we look
at the simple example we'll we'll see an
example of that how it's it's very clean
there's a minimal amount of boilerplate
and a minim minimal amount of syntactic
noise for you to consume these
interfaces and that is all done through
the magic of template classes variatic
templates
and
implementation details that are hiding
all this noise from you now that
if for some reason
you need that lower level access
you can obtain it it's it's not like
they're hiding things from you
and you have no control over that you
can get access to the lower level
facilities
if you if for some reason you need to
perhaps you're trying to migrate some
legacy code up to using winrt
and you need to deal with some low-level
com style
method invocation you know via atl or or
something like that
some in older code but for for newer
code that you're writing from scratch it
it looks very similar to c sharp as
we'll see
all the error handling is done with
exceptions
except when throwing an exception could
cross an abi boundary
so for instance
com
does not use exceptions internally
but we want to use exceptions so we
don't have to do deal with all the
testing of error codes that are mandated
by com
so what happens is suppose we are using
winrt to implement a method on an
interface
and we throw an exception
the shim that is
provided by the winrt implementation
we'll catch our exception turn that into
the corresponding error code and make
sure that it's the error code that is
returned by our com interface
so that the
color which may not be written in c plus
plus the color can be written in some
other language like you know pascal
visual basic what have you c sharp
the caller will receive that error code
and then it's uh usually there's some
piece of language infrastructure in the
caller's
side of things that turns that error
code back into the normal
error handling mechanism for that
language you know for
dot net it probably gets turned back
into an exception
um constructors and destructors are used
to manage object lifetimes and keep
track of open references to interfaces
so if you
have
create if you've created an object and
you've stored in a local variable and
then you have
another local variable where you assign
it
because it's assignment that now you've
got two local variables referring to the
same object and so the reference count
is increased they have move support so
that if what you intended was the the
new
uh the left-hand side of the new
assignment wasn't if your intention was
to transfer ownership to that object
then you could do a stood move as you
assign it
and
the original object
original variable rather will no longer
hold a reference to the object is just
an empty container
but mostly
object values just look like regular
types you don't need to do smart
pointers yourself
if you've done
atl com programming in the past you you
had to
it was up to you to maintain the smart
pointers that wrap the interfaces
here the language projection takes care
of all that for you so
you just get to write code more
naturally and you don't have to worry
about
managing the smart pointers yourself
and because everything is a header
implementation it provides more
optimizing opportunities to the compiler
and this results in
smaller and faster executables
they also have co-routine support
as i looked at some of the
implementation
it looked to me like they were using
the c plus 17 co routine support from
experimental so the headers say bracket
experimental slash code routines
um and they're using co-routines for
asynchronous operations so a lot of
the win rt
uh
methods and
objects are ac have have asynchronous
operations
because they're um
you know that's a more modern design
style so if you're reading from a file
or you're reading from something
something on the network or you're doing
any kind of communication that could be
potentially
blocking
usually what happens is they are
returning an asynchronous result and
then you can either synchronize on the
asynchronous result if you need it right
away or you can hold that result for a
while until you need it to give that
asynchronous operation a chance to
complete and then you can obtain the
result
so they're using co-routine mechanisms
to
implement that
and
this cppcon 2016 talk embracing standard
c plus plus for the windows runtime that
you can find on youtube
uh that's the presentation i mentioned
with james mcnellis and
kenny kerr
that describes in detail uh how a lot of
this stuff is implemented if you're
interested but um
i think it's kind of an it's kind of a
nice to know
level of information it's not need to
know if you want to consume the winr rt
api from c plus you don't need to know
those things there's not even
stuff in there i would say is need to
know because of like gotcha corner cases
they've just done a really good job on
the language projection you can just use
it as is and it just kind of all works
as you would expect
so
that's how it works but how well does it
works um
so the previous
solution for consuming winrt from c plus
plus was a
special version of the compiler called c
plus plus cx
and
james and kenny in their presentation do
a breakdown showing how
the c plus winner t language projection
compares to c plus plus cx and how it
compares to net
and
in in their examples and i and i can
believe that this would be fairly
consistent across all application
domains
the c plus plus when rt components are
smaller and faster than their c plus
plus cx implementations
and
both c plus plus implementations are
smaller and faster than the dot net
implementations
you also from c plus of course you have
the advantage
that you can determine deterministically
manage resource lifetimes
so
no garbage collection
you can have
you know
custom allocators for improving the
efficiency of allocating and
deallocating lots of small objects of
the same type
arena allocators etc
they've also
um now kenny kerr create started
creating this language projection before
he went to work from microsoft but now
he has been working at microsoft for
probably
probably like five seven years and
that's at this point
and so they've closely worked with the
compiler team to recognize various com
idioms and various winrt idioms
so that the compiler can optimize them
and if you're
a little bit familiar with com as i said
every object has to implement i unknown
and that's how you navigate between
interface implementations on a single
object instance
there are i unknown contains a query
interface method that you can use to say
you know here's the universal identifier
for this other interface do you
implement it and it says yes or no and
if it says yes it gives you back a
pointer to the interface
now the
list of interfaces that an object
implements is known at compile time
so
kenny actually describes how they were
able to create a const expert function
that would
determine at compile time whether or not
query interface would succeed or not
and then based on that they can decorate
query interface as a pure function and
this allows the compiler to apply more
aggressive optimizations to it
so i thought that was kind of a neat
little you know way down in the plumbing
kind of trick
but as a result of these compiler
optimizations
the
c plus winrt code is able to be smaller
and faster than the counterparts in
other languages which i found really
interesting
so what does this look like well here is
the entire program
for
a little piece of code that goes off and
i have a
rss feed that i create this is uh this
url is on my personal account on my isp
and it enumerates out
the latest pdfs that have been scanned
into this vintage
computing repository called bitsavers
and so this code
the first thing at the top there the
pragma lib is just so we get
a link into
the boilerplate infrastructure that
every winrt application has to have
so everything
you see on the screen here is all that
is needed to compile this file and get a
working executable there's no
extra linking steps that need to be
specified or any
compiler flags or anything so the
winrt headers those are the
headers generated by the
cppwinrt
language projection tool
and of course iostream is our friend
that we're just going to use to write
out the output
everything
is inside the winrt namespace
and each
set of interfaces described in winrt
is inside a namespace
and you can pretty much see that the
namespaces map to
what is
the prefix of the header that we
included so
windows.foundation.collections
all of that stuff is inside the windows
foundation namespace
and
windows web syndication
namespace brings in
the
or makes visible the
declarations for syndication client
syndication feed
and syndication item which i've just
written it as const auto item but the
actual type is syndication item
so we got a
uri class that lets us build a url
and a syndication client
and from that client we retrieve
the rss feed from that syndication
client and that's an asynchronous
operation but right here we just method
chain on the get because we immediately
need the results we're not gonna we
don't have any else any other things we
can do usefully while that
fetch is taking place asynchronously
and then we can just do a range for loop
over the items collection and for each
item we can get the text of the title
and then we can print out
the title as a c style string
now
h string you might notice is a little
different being an all lower case
and as i mentioned earlier there is
marshalling across the
com boundary between the language and
com
and strings are one of the things that
have to be marshaled
and it's a standard com
data type
so instead of it being provided by
a winrt
interface
it is provided as part of
the infrastructure
so
each string is a class that is provided
by winrt it's its implementation is
basically fixed it's provided in a base
dot h if you go look in the headers
and that's what gives us our ability to
get strings in and out of winrt
so let's go take a look at
what this code looks like
so here was that here's that exact code
that i just showed you now i created
this by just saying
create a blank oops create a blank
windows console application
project so this project doesn't know
anything about winrt it doesn't know
anything about
the language projection it doesn't know
anything
[Music]
standard c plus
the only setting i had to change from
the default
was i went to
well it's bubbled up here i had to
change this from the the default is iso
c plus plus 14.
so that was the only thing i had to
change was to change it to
c plus plus 17.
and if we
here let me get my
output window over here so we can just
see the build going
if i just say
rebuild
it'll compile this now you'll notice
that it takes quite a while to compile
that source.cpp even though it doesn't
have much in it
and that's because these generated
headers
these generated headers
can can contain quite a bit of code
since it's a header only library there's
there's it's all in there
and so they each
header that is generated for a namespace
for a set of interfaces and so on is
obviously including other headers to get
other things that it depends on
so it can be quite a bit so
generally the recommendation is to use
either pre-compiled headers
or to use modules now that we have
modules in c plus plus 20.
and the hope is that um
a module-based version of these headers
will be
uh
much more efficient because they can
provide they can provide
the pre-compiled module implementations
as part of the sdk i don't think they've
shipped that yet
um
and in fact
on my little sample here in order to get
it to run correctly
i had to target
a slightly older version
of the sdk the current version most
recent version i have on my machine is
1n041
and that had a hard time with some of
the asynchronous infrastructure so i
just went one version back and
from your solution there's this retarget
solution
that can be used to take care of that
but
let's take a look here this uh init
apartment
if you're if you're not
familiar with com programming
comp programming has
threading models
and the most commonly used
threading model is so is the so-called
single threaded apartment model and
that's what this is setting up so this
is basically
our com initialization that function is
provided to us by winrt
so if we
drill into it we can see here we are in
that base.h header that i mentioned this
is all the common
base infrastructure stuff that's needed
by
any
winrt application and you can see all
they're doing is delegating off to
the
ro initialize function that's provided
in winrt
and that comes back with one of these
comh results and they're checking to see
if the call succeeded and if it didn't
succeed it turns it into an exception
so because it's header only if you're
really if you're curious about how any
of these things are implemented you can
always drill down so here's their
implementation for the uri class
you can see they're saying it derives
from
i uri runtime class and then it has a
requirement that
the uri so here's curious recurring
template pattern
uri requires istringable and it requires
eye runtime
class with absolute canonical uri
here's the
methods
that are exposed on that class so we've
got a
default constructor
oh sorry we have constructors with
parameters
and there's a couple of
static methods
and if you're at all familiar with com
programming you might be saying wait
wait wait wait how can you do static
methods
uh and
they have a way that static methods turn
into
uh you instantiate an object that holds
methods for all the static methods on
your class and then that uh
one instance of that
object holding the static methods for
your
class that one instance can serve
all instances of the class right because
they're static methods they don't vary
behavior based on
the instance otherwise they would be
instance methods and not static methods
and the
obtaining of that interface pointer to
that object that represents the static
methods is cached so you're not
querying it over and over if you're
calling these static methods repeatedly
and so on they've
explained this in their uh cppcon talk
it's it's quite um
interesting from an implementation
perspective but from a client
perspective it's just like yeah all i
need to know is if i need to unescape
component
i can just call that method statically
and
in the winrt documentation for these
interfaces it will be shown as a
static method so you can know which ones
are static and which ones are instances
so here i am i'm building a url etc etc
if we
want to step through this code
we can run it real quick
let me get the
console window where you can see it
so here i am at my breakpoint if i
want to
i can step into
these methods if if i want their
visual studio has a feature called not
just my code is what they call it and so
because these headers are coming from
the system they're not marked as my code
so by default if you step over or step
in it's the same
because it doesn't consider the winrt
language projection to be your code
you can force a step in
there's multiple ways to do it but one
way i do it is to just do control f11
which kind of steps you into the
assembly language
and we jump through a little bit and
then we can do control f11 again so now
we see we're in the default constructor
for syndication client which delegates
to another constructor for syndication
client that goes and gets the factory
that says this is how i create
syndication client objects and then it
ends up calling activate instance this
is all the low-level calm machinery that
you would have had to do if you were
doing it yourself
which is
maybe interesting to you but the whole
point of this is so we don't have to do
all that junk ourselves
so if we can just step back out here
i've gotten
now i can step over this you can see it
takes a bit because it's going out on
the internet and fetching that rss feed
from my
internet account and now we've got
the feed locally in memory and we can
start walking over the items and we can
start printing them out and
you can see there's the first one this
is just the title
of the item
so it's not printing out the url or
anything else it's just printing out the
title and if we run through that
we can see that yeah it printed out
a bunch of titles from that rss feed
now i don't know about you but if you've
ever written c plus trying to
do some
you know http fetches and get an rss
feed and parse the rss feed and try to
extract stuff out of it just so you can
get some
some text i mean i have never written so
little code to do so much when
interacting with
you know rss feeds and law like that
even
when i've
the code that i wrote to generate this
rss feed as a perl script that uses some
pearl modules to do rss feeds for
generating it and that code is
you know like pages and pages worth just
to be able to generate the rss file
so to me this is like amazingly
productive for
getting at some of these
uh
internet types that we're so used to
dealing with that are very easy to deal
with from
a.net programming perspective but have
been frankly just a big pain in the butt
to try and access from c plus and even
though this is windows only i am looking
at this code and i'm saying you know
what if i need to whip up something
quick and
it needs to interact with some of these
um you know kind of web land things but
for whatever reason i need to do it in c
plus plus and and c sharp isn't going to
cut it
or maybe i'm not up to speed on c sharp
but i am up to speed on c plus plus this
feels really just like c plus plus value
types i don't see any smart pointer junk
here
the only weird thing is this init
apartment but it's i just need to
remember to do that in my main function
before i do anything else i don't really
need to know what it's doing or why it
has to be there but if i do that
then i'm good to go with all this other
stuff
and
the only thing that might be a bit of a
pain
is the fact that all the strings
are wide character strings but
you know you should be kind of
comfortable with utf anyway
if you need to marshal it into a narrow
string
there are ways that you can do that
conversion if for some reason you need
to get it into a you know really if you
look look at my output here oh it's gone
but oh no there it is uh there's no
i mean it's it's transported in
xml
and the xml can have utf strings in it
but i happen to know that from the way
this is generated that it's always
guaranteed to be ascii
so we could have you know
bashed it in to ask you over here if we
needed to in this particular case
but um
doesn't hurt to be multi-language aware
and be unicode enabled so
that's why my url is a
long character string literal and that's
why my new line character is a long
character little
so let's look at a more complicated
example
because i mean that's nice and all but
it's if we're going for winrt we're
probably interested in like designing
our user interface using xaml using the
um
xaml editing capabilities that are in
visual studio and having that be
supported so my other example that we're
going to show is this photo editor
and
let me stop debugging that
so
this is a sample that microsoft has up
on github let me get this solution
window over here so you can see it
and we'll bring the output window over
here too
actually we'll make this a little bigger
because we're gonna
take a look at some of this stuff
so let's just run it and we'll see what
this looks like first so
if we run this thing
let's get that okay so it has gone to my
photos folder and shown me a grid of my
photos
and let's we can pick a photo
and then we can
pick an effect to run on this photo so
let's say we're going to invert it we
can apply
we can go over here and zoom this out to
fit screen
and if we don't want to see that little
edit box we can hide that and
all of this user interface
and go back here and select a new photo
and select a different effect let's say
we'll do a blur
and how much are we going to blur it
we're going to
can see it's blurring in real time as
i'm dragging the slider
we can apply that and then let's you
know make that fit to screen again or
show actual size
so all of the processing
for this application
is written using c plus when rt
the user interface code so this title
box up here
the image display down here this little
zoom button and the corresponding
controls and this little edit button and
the corresponding controls
we can reset remove all the effects
select another effect like uh it's not
the best user interface design here
we've got low contrast text but we can
do a color shift
we can change the temperature
and the tint
have you all all that user interface
interaction
is all specified through
a xaml file
so in our
application here we've got this app
zamel but the more interesting part here
is the main page
and detail page xaml
so here is the
kind of the design view
and then down here actually let's uh
hide that okay
down here is the raw xml that is
in the xaml and
if you've done any of this sort of thing
it it's a
declarative style user interface
paradigm so what we're doing is using
a xml file to describe the user
interface elements and their properties
and how the user interface elements are
connected to each other
and it also is using a data binding
template
so with
data binding it's a declarative way of
saying well it's a list view well what
are the items in the list well the items
in the list are obtained from a data
binding
and it's the data binding that is
accessed by the application when it goes
to fill in the data it's not the
directly accessing the control
and by
providing that extra level of
indirection
what you end up with is a situation
where
as most of us are working on teams
you have a ui designer that's working in
the xaml editor and is iterating on the
xaml on the presentation of the data and
collaborating with the developers just
to understand what the data bindings are
between the application data and the
user interface
but the ui designer can work in parallel
and iterate on their design without
having to obtain
new builds from the development team
because the the build is talking to the
data binding so they can adjust the
properties of the user interface
and how it is attached to the data
binding and they can change it from a
list view to a grid view to
check boxes or what have you they can
experiment with different user interface
choices
and quickly try them out without having
to rebuild the code so that's the whole
point of xaml based user interface
design
compared to
tightly coupling these things like it
would be and say an mfc application
or a traditional c plus application
so
the way um visual studio does it is that
each of these
xaml files has code behind file
so here on the detail page
here is this detail page dot cpp now
this contains the manually written code
so we see here that we've got
a detail page object and it's inside
this
implementation namespace now personally
i would not have put this inside the
winrt namespace because to me i would
have viewed that like namespace standard
i i would have stayed out of there and
just
you know i would have just called it
photo editor at the top but this is how
that sample is written
and you can see it's similar to how the
code that we looked at before they've
got a precompiled header to pull in all
of that winrt stuff
which is going to be megabytes of header
pull it in in a precompiled header
more ideally c plus plus 20 we would use
modules
again i don't think they've
got a module aware implementation of the
language projection yet
but that's where they're headed they've
said that that's where they're going to
go to
so i would not be surprised to see it
show up at some point
and similar to what we saw in our small
example this you know using namespace
winrt to bring in the core winrt
infrastructure things like h string and
a knit apartment those kinds of things
and then they're using the namespaces
for
the
winrt objects that they are using
in this code
and although
you can see my resharper is saying hey
um you did a using namespace microsoft
graphics canvas up here so therefore
specifying it again here is kind of
redundant
but i am kind of of the opinion that
when you're bringing in these namespaces
it's less ambiguous to the reader
to specify it out in full
um but that's why it's ghosted like that
you can you'll notice that
although some of these prefixes are
ghosted by resharper all of the terminal
namespaces are not ghosted which means
that we actually are using something
in this file from all of those
namespaces that are listed
and you know if you look at this code i
mean it
it looks like really straightforward
stuff i i don't see any smart pointer
noise i don't see any ad ref release
noise i don't see any try catch noise
i don't see any of the
low level machinery bubbling up into my
face and irritating me because it's all
been hidden away in the language
projection
and as i mentioned if for some reason
perhaps there's some case where they
couldn't quite optimize it as
efficiently as you would be able to
optimize it by hand and it showed up in
a performance profile if you need to you
can dip down
to the lower level and
get
the lower level abi because it's a
header only library right so you can
always drill into any one of these
things and see how they do it here's
let's go back we were calling
go to state method
and if we look at that it's an impul you
know on doing a call factory
where it is
making a method call and supplying a
lambda
you know and the and the you know the
lambda
is doing looks like this is a state
machine
visual state manager so it's doing a
state transition so it's doing go to
state
again so if you needed to
for some reason
if a performance profile showed that any
of this
language projection was getting in your
way and causing you a problem perhaps in
some
particular case it was you know doing
unnecessary allocation and reallocation
you can always expand it because it
comes from a header only library you can
drill into the implementation grab it
pull it apart
do the necessary things to get rid of
that inefficiency but i have a suspicion
that
they've already
done that sort of uh profiling
you can see those methods that we looked
at are not particularly complicated
you know they're just simple
marshaling and delegation so it's
unlikely that any performance problems
are going to be originating in the
language projection but
in the rare weird case where that does
happen
since it's header only
you can always drill down as low as you
need to go
so
that is basically it i was
pleasantly surprised that this little
example here of getting items off an rss
feed and dumping them out was just like
a simple one page piece of code that
even fits on a slide
and the only thing i needed to do in my
project settings
was to switch it to use
c plus 17
and other than that
it just compiled and worked poof like
right out of the box i didn't need to
adjust any linker settings i didn't need
to do any
now this this windows app thing here
with the pragma lib
there's almost certainly a way that you
could go here to add reference
and
obtain it that way if we look back at
the photo editor
they've got a bunch of the windows
runtime
assemblies referenced here
so
you know when you're hooked in through
and you'll notice this is a universal
windows project whereas my simple
example is just a plain old
you know standard console application i
wrote my own main
uh if we look over here that was
something that we
you might have noticed
if we step into this
program from the very beginning
we'll see that we get into
a xaml generated main it's a win main
in fact it's a
wide character signature win main
not that we're using this string
and
you know the first thing they do is
called winrt and it apartment and then
they call application start with a
lambda that creates
it makes an instance of our app
because you
if you have a xaml application you
call xaml
application start and you give it an
instance
well you give it a
in this case it's a lambda but
i believe in
other languages it's something like
it ends up being a factory that creates
your app
we can drill into this
make function and see that it's a
variatic template function
and this is to support
all the types of
interfaces that may be
implemented by your
object that it is making an instance of
this is this is a generic make function
that can make any object
and you see that it does a couple of
checks here
to find out you know we're doing a
constex per check to find out does this
thing
is one of the um
interfaces that is implemented by the
default interface is implemented by the
destination type if it is an eye
activation factory
then we delegate to a specialized make
function that that handles
that if it is
a
i believe this is the case where
the
object we're requesting to be made
is composable and
we need to
cast the result
so this as function is is basically an
interface casting
mechanism
to cast from
say as i mentioned there's i unknown and
com that you use to query for the
interfaces that are implemented by an
object well if an object implements ifu
and i bar but ifu and ibar don't inherit
from one another in any
way then that's there's no way to reach
an ifu from an i bar or an i bar from
our
ifoo directly by like casting to a base
class or to a more derived class what
you have to do is use query interface to
obtain
the one interface pointer from the other
and that's what their as function does
so they've you know
in their little make function
they've done some constants per checking
so the
the relationship between these
interfaces is known at compile time
so the constexpr if
can identify that scenario
and delegate to the appropriate
specialized factory function
or down here it is a
comcast interface cast
so they can
handle they have one function that
basically knows how to make all these
different types of objects even though
the
the scenario or the sequence of
operations has to take place in order to
create these different objects is
different depending on the relationship
of the object so
lots of
c plus magic going on under the hood
and
in the end it just means hey uh
i just write some really straightforward
code and it just works
now you might have noticed if your eyes
are keen
that hey you might have noticed hey this
is generated code
but it's got an application
type
mentioned in it
so where did that come
from and
in
this whole uh
visual studio kind of
um
how do you call it uh
xaml designing world right where the
visual studio is generating code
that corresponds to code that's in your
xaml file xml in your xaml file
so they
that the build system created this
generated files folder this x64 debug
this is where all our obj is right
beside we're used to that from buildings
regular c plus plus application cell
windows
but this
generated files folder
is where all the
magic
ide generated boilerplate that
glues together the xaml
to our
application code
that's where
it all ended up over here
and
i'm not 100
certain uh the reason why but obviously
this app
dot xaml was copied from our source file
directory over here so this
this is our source file as we obtained
it from github
and the build system copied it over to
here and then generated a header file
and
a uh
why do we have an h and an hpp i guess
the h is if we were going to consume
this from c for some reason
i'm not i'm not 100 certain on the role
that all these
generated files play but you notice
there's also some cpp files that are in
here
uh
i'm assuming that this one with a g is
generated with some data substituted in
from a template and this one is just
um
needed but copied over from some place
where visual studio decided to get it
um i haven't worked in like.net xaml
land for
a good number of years so
a lot of this stuff has evolved to where
i'm not tracking all the details
but
point is
we were able to do xaml based uia design
so that decouples the ui designing
from the backend business logic
and the bridge between the two is the
data binding that attaches controls to
data sources
so our business logic
responds to events fills data sources
with data those data sources are bound
into the ui the ui gets updated
and as you saw when we were running that
application
it's you know pretty decent and
efficient obviously
you you fill a grid with you know a
million grid items it's going to take a
while but
you know there's always a stupid way to
use something smart
so
that i think gives you
an idea of how all this stuff works
and
for
simple things it's simple
and for
more elaborate things
we've got
high level tools that let us leverage
the facilities inside visual studio for
team oriented ui design
and we can write our you know business
logic and c plus plus where it's going
to be nice and efficient and fast and
low resource consumption
which is the way we want it
so if there are any questions we can
take those now
and if you want to ask a question by
voice don't forget to unmute your
microphone first
or if you don't want to talk there's
also the chat window
you can type a question in there
okay well since there doesn't seem to be
any okay go
say ahead you
um
you're welcome
any other questions or comments
thank you
okay well let me uh